The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: So today
is all about you.
We are introducing Project Two.
We are starting off with
the Project One pitch
presentations, then
we're going to have
prototype demonstrations.
The idea is that
everyone in class
should have heard about all
the games that were made
and should have at least
seen all the games be played.
it's going to be
kind of difficult,
but we're going
to try to do that.
After that, we're
going to form teams.
So we're going to choose a few
of these games and form teams
around them.
And then after that,
assuming we have time left,
we're going to work
in our new teams.
You're going to rewrite that
Project One vision statement
and you're going to modify
the paper prototype on volume
here has a group just to kind
of see what the mechanics were
and what you're going to
have to do for Project Two.
So starting off, Project Two--
it's another low fidelity
prototyping, but
this is more digital.
So you're going to actually
make a digital game.
We're asking to create
this digital prototype
in a short time frame.
You had about a week
to do Project One.
You're going to have about
two weeks to do Project Two.
There will be some of
the work done in class.
Unfortunately, it's not
going to be the programming.
That's going to happen
outside of class.
In class, we're doing
a lot of the meetings
and a lot of the project
management stuff in class.
And we'll be walking
through a lot of that.
You're going to be basing that
game off of a Project One game.
And then yeah, we're going to
integrate project management
concepts into your process,
and we'll be talking about some
of that stuff
starting Wednesday.
Extra goals-- you're
going to be working
as a team for the first time
using a common game engine.
So hopefully some of the
lessons from that game
engine tutorial we did
last week work out-- I
think that was last week,
yeah-- work out for you.
You're going to be
doing version control,
so it looked like
we had everybody
able to use some kind of version
control with all those engines.
That's a good sign.
And then you're also going to be
managing your time commitments.
This is the first
time you're going
to have six people on one
project for this class,
and then you're going
to continue like that
for the rest of the semester.
So coming up with
strategies on how
to work with each other, how
to maximize the work you do
in person, and what you
can do when you're not
next to each other, when you're
working from your dorm room,
from a study area,
things like that.
So the deliverables
for this one-- today,
we are going to do this
workshop, this team information
workshop.
On Wednesday, we're going to
be work shopping the product
backlog, and you're
going to be turning in
to Stellar-- actually, I
meant the vision statement.
But on Wednesday,
by the end of class,
we'd like you turn
in the Stellar
an updated vision statement.
So take the statement you were
working on for Project One,
modify it based on
the new team you have.
You'll do a little bit
of that today in class,
and then you'll turn it in by
the end of class on Wednesday
to Stellar.
The following week, you're
going to turn in to Stellar
before class starts a
product backlog based
on the workshop you
did the week prior.
And in class, we're going to
talk about sprint back task
lists.
So you don't know what a
sprint task list is right now.
You don't know what
estimates are right now.
You'll be working
on that on Monday,
and then each team will give
a short presentation to us
about the work that you did.
On Wednesday you'll turn in
that task list you created.
And in class on
Wednesday, we'll be
playing all the digital games.
So you have to have
something running
by Wednesday at 1:00 PM.
It could be running and broken.
You might not get much
good feedback out of it,
but it must be running
by Wednesday at 1:00 PM.
And then the following
Monday, the project is due.
Yeah, really, really short.
On Stellar you're going to
turn a whole bunch of stuff.
All of your games should
compile out to HTML,
either be playable on a website
or use a website plug-in
like Unity or Flash or whatnot.
So there is more details
in the handout in Stellar.
I updated that this morning,
so please take a look at that
once your teams are formed.
So it's probably one
of the first things
you should do is take a
look at those requirements.
Again, you'll need a
written a written postmortem
from each of you.
We'll ask for a design
change log, which
your first entry will be today.
You'll need an updated
vision statement
if anything changed from the
one you turned in on whatever I
said it was, Wednesday.
If anything's changed,
you'll turn it in again.
And you'll be doing
focus test reports.
So we're doing
some focus testing,
some testing in the next week.
And then, you'll also do
a postmortem presentation.
And so, this presentation
will actually
be five minutes per team.
The requirements
are on the handout,
and we'll talk about it a little
more later in the next week
or so.
But basically, it's
tell us what went right,
tell us what went wrong,
tell us what you learned.
We don't necessarily want to
see the game being played.
We want to see what you've
learned from the game,
so highlight that with
screenshots, with video, stuff
like that.
All right, so this is what
we're doing for the next--
we've got 15 slots-- so for
the next 15 or so minutes--
elevator pitches.
Why are we asking you
to do an elevator pitch?
If you can succinctly describe
your game in one minute,
it's probably pretty well
scoped for Project Two.
Also, you probably have a handle
on what you're actually making.
You know what the game's about.
You can describe the
game to another person.
To us that means,
great, that project
is probably going to be
a Project Two project.
If you have a little bit of
difficulty describing it,
if you go a little
bit over time,
we're going to allow you
to go over time, but don't.
Why do I even tell you that?
I just messed
everything up, didn't I?
But if there's some
issues going on with that,
that'll let us know a little bit
about the scope of the project.
Don't show us the game, don't
use visuals, don't use laptops.
You're in an elevator
with an executive.
They said, fine, you
got a minute of my time.
Tell me what you're
trying to do.
Bam, convince them
that your game is cool,
depends on what your game does.
In this particular case,
we want to know why it's
about planning for randomness.
Remember, that's our design
constraint for the Project
One and Project Two.
What about your game is
planning for randomness?
What is the core piece
of game play in it.
Remember in your
vision statement,
in one of the
versions, we asked you
for 20 or 30 seconds
of game play.
That's a great thing
to put in a pitch.
So you've got all the material,
just take your minute, go.
Afterwards, we're going
to do demonstrations,
and I'll bring that
slide up later.
But basically we're
not going to just rely
on you talking about your game.
We're going to be able to see
all the games being played.
And we're going to, again,
try to get everybody
able to see all the games
being played if they
haven't been played already.
And after that, we're
going to try to form
teams, which is really hard.
So that comes later.
All right, any questions
before we move on?
Any additional
comments from y'all?
Oh yeah, remember to check
handout 2 on Stellar.
So yes.
by the end of class today.
All right, so first
team is Lazy Beaver.
Again, you only need
one person from the team
to come up if you don't
all want to come up.
Come up here, stand
about right here,
there's a microphone right here.
It'll capture you-- talk.
Lazy Beaver, come on down.
STUDENT 1: All
right, hi everyone.
Our name is called Lazy Beaver.
Lazy Beaver is a
survival game in which
players must take on a chaotic
world full of surprises.
These surprises come in the form
of random environmental events
such as hurricanes,
predators, and even Ebola.
The player takes
one action every day
which either replenishes or
depletes their finite resources
with the objective of
surviving the elements in order
to build a set number of dams.
Since the environment
is so unpredictable,
the player must carefully
plan their actions or risk
losing by running out
any of their resources.
This lets the player
either choose to be risky
or play it safe.
The digital prototype will
maintain the same core gameplay
of choosing actions,
reacting to the environment,
and preparing for disasters.
We will take the opportunity
to carefully balance
events and resources to tune
the difficulty to appeal
to all types of players.
Lazy Beaver should
move on to Project Two
because during
testing players found
our game both delightful
and difficult.
Also, the technical
scope of the game
is fitting for Project
Two's timeline,
and the mechanics
of the game are well
suited for the preparing
for randomness theme.
PROFESSOR 1: Dragon's Lair.
Come on down.
STUDENT 2: Hello, everybody.
Our game is called
Dragon's Lair.
The game's point is
you are an adventurer
and you come into
a dragon's lair.
You have 20 actions you
take, but after every time
you take action, the dragon
destroys one of them.
The point is you want
to try to collect
as much gold as possible.
The game ends when all the parts
are either discarded by you
or destroyed by the dragon.
And then you count up how
much gold you got at the end.
The game is lost,
thought, if you
run out the dragon's patience,
because the dragon can only
put up with you being
in its lair for so long.
The game would be
good for Project Two
because it has a small scope.
The only thing we want to
do for the digital prototype
is get some artwork in there,
a little bit of ambient music,
add a timer so
that people aren't
taking too long at each turn.
And add a high score
table because the game
has high replay ability value.
So we want people to be able
to see their achievements.
People found it fun and it
was difficult, and so yeah,
we think it's a good game.
PROFESSOR 1: Great, thank you.
Fight or Flight, come on down.
STUDENT 3: Why is it that in
every Indiana Jones movie ever
there's a temple
that gets destroyed.
A temple gets destroyed
because it turns out
that running out of a temple
is really, really fun.
Our game-- Fight or
Flight-- forces the players
to run from a randomly but not.
Environment that gets randomly
destroyed behind or in
front of them and
balance their actions
between fighting their
pursuers and just
running as quickly as possible.
It works for Project Two because
it's fun, dynamic, and actually
pretty simple at its core.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 1: Plunder Winds.
STUDENT 4: Hi, everyone.
Our game is Plunder
Winds, a pirate themed
treasure hunting game.
Our game is based around
three simple core mechanics
that interact with each other.
The first one is a random
encounter mechanic,
which controls the probability
of finding treasure.
And you can affect this
as the game progresses.
An exploration mechanic,
which tells you
what the risk level of
nearby encounters will be.
And then wind mechanic,
which limits your moving
and forces the player to make
strategic decisions about where
they move.
Our game's digital prototype
would have the same core
mechanics as our
paper prototype,
but it would be faster
and more graphics
so it'd be easier for
players to pick up.
We could also add on unique
encounters and abilities
to improve replay ability.
So our project should
on to Project Two
since it's easy to implement.
And also, throughout
play testing,
we found that players
found it easy to pick up,
but also found it
hard to master.
So you should come join
our crew-- Plunder Winds.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: Blind Aliens.
WT.
STUDENT 5: It's a working title.
PROFESSOR 1: Uh-huh.
STUDENT 5: Hi, everyone.
We're Blind Aliens.
Our game is Blind Aliens.
The premise of the game
is aliens, blind aliens,
have invaded the Earth and you
are one of very few surviving
humans.
And the game is very simple,
it's in a very small room.
There's aliens that come
in through random gates
around the edges.
And they randomly roam
around searching for you,
but they can't see you
because they're blind.
So you have three options.
You can sneak away very slowly.
Or you can run very
fast, which is loud.
Or you have a gun, you can
shoot at them, which is also
very loud and you'll be risking
getting discovered and eaten
alive.
So the game should
move on to Project Two
because it's very simple.
During testing, we
found that people
found it very engaging in
that it was not boring at all.
So, yeah.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR 1: Next up is Live On.
STUDENT 6: Hi, everyone.
Live On is a
survival themed game
that takes place in a
hexgrid based world.
The player needs to stay
alive and move from the start
to the goal.
There are four type
possible terrain
to raise-- river, mountain,
plain, and forest-- each
with simple costs and benefits.
The key mechanic for the
game is that at every turn,
the player needs to
choose which tile
to move on to next based on what
information he has available.
So the player only has
limited vision on one hand
is important to
choose grids that
will lead to a good
location for the next move.
On the other hand,
the player need
to plan for the
[INAUDIBLE] tiles
that he can't see at the moment.
The game will be a good
project for Projust Two
because, in my opinion,
not only does making plans
based on incomplete
information and random events
lies at the heart of
the games mechanic,
we implement a good set
of tradeoffs and balances
between the different
terrains that
serve to offer the player
meaningful, consequential
choices of which path to go.
In the digital version, in
addition to the core game play,
we seek to add randomized
map generation and multiple
characters with
different abilities
to further enhance the gameplay.
We'll stay with a 2D game,
the grid representation
of the world, and turn
based actions, as opposed
to continuous work over
the time game plan.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 1: Beaver Evolutions.
STUDENT 7: All right,
so Beaver Evolution
is exactly what it sounds like.
You have a colony
of beavers, and you
have to fight against nature
and evolve your beavers
over generations to
survive against the trials
and tribulations that
nature will throw at you.
The core mechanic
of the game is based
around making a choice between
three different options
for every generation.
You can either build your
exam, popular beavers,
or choose an evolution
traits help develop you
colony to fight against the
natural disasters that will
try to hinder your progress.
Our game is going to be a
great game for Project Two
because we have a lot of
ideas for implementing it
in a real time world,
currently as a turned based
game were you make a
choice and then you
respond to a natural disaster.
We think that it'll be great
to implement a real time
game because you will be able
to respond to natural disasters
and allocate your beavers
to either work on you
dam or work on evolving.
And you have to have
quick reflexes in order
to survive through the
game and win the game.
Thanks.
PROFESSOR 1: Comcastic.
STUDENT 8: Hello.
Comcastic is a cable
monopoly simulator
where you are trying to place
your oddly-shaped service
centers into an
existing city landscape.
Your goal is to
make as much money
as possible while caring about
your customers' satisfaction.
STUDENT 9: So in the
digital prototype
we're basically going to have
a grid where all the homes
and businesses are
laid out, and the user
will see the inconvenient-shaped
pieces for your service
centers.
And then, when they
select a center,
they will see how many
people it can serve
and the price that it'll
cost them each month.
And then, they will need to
place these on the board.
STUDENT 10: We think this is
a good project for our Project
Two because we've found
that playing the game
and creating the game
is both very simple.
And we found that it
was really engaging.
We had a few random
testers kinda
describe it as a strategic
version of Tetris, basically.
PROFESSOR 1: Sparkly Redemption.
STUDENT 11: Boosh!
You're a lady with only
one arm, and your other arm
is a gun that shoots things.
You're a disgrace in your
nation and your only chance
at redemption is to get
all of the sparklies.
However, the place where
all the sparklies are
are filled with monsters.
And depending on which
sparklies you pick up,
sometimes you get
better arm gun powers,
but sometimes the monsters
change their behavior
and you have to adapt
to that, or just
be strategic about
picking up your sparklies.
Our game is super cool because,
even with our simple paper
prototype version, people
had a lot of fun with it.
And the sort of game
that's pretty easy
to implement at a most basic,
just fun to play stage.
But then it's good to
add stuff on top of it,
like extra monster behaviors
and super shooty arm powers.
Plus you're a lady
with one arm and a gun
that shoots thing,
which I think is cool.
PROFESSOR 1: Modgi Dice.
STUDENT 12: Hey, everyone.
So Modgi Dice is a math
puzzle game like Sudoku
or 2048 where the user navigates
a dice around a square grid,
rolling the dice
one side at a time,
and adding that side
of dice to the square.
The cool mechanic
of this game is
that each square is modular
7 and the goal of the game
is to reset all of
the squares to zero.
This game will work
well for Project Two
because it is a fast paced
mover game kind of like 2048.
And you can move those around
very quickly while also
having to plan out your moves.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 1: City Evacuation.
STUDENT 13: In City
Evacuation, your goal
is to escape the
city because there's
an earthquake in your city.
And you have to do
that while saving
three friends along the way.
And what will happen
during the game
is you might get
hit by an explosion,
or abridgement fall down, or
you might have some [INAUDIBLE].
STUDENT 14: As far
as the digital scope,
we're going build
a 2D game that's
dependant on your dice roll and
will generate random disaster
cards that will come
up and the hardest part
will be the graphics.
STUDENT 15: We think this is
a good project for number two
because there's a
lot of randomness,
but we also give the player
tools to plan and strategize
around that.
Additionally, people thought
it was really fun to play.
And though it's sort of simple
to implement at the beginning,
we think there's amble
challenge in the graphics,
the sounds, and the
animations that can be
built on top of that framework.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
Shoutkey.com/doorway?
STUDENT 16: All right,
the next 12 hours,
our game is called
Shoutkey.com/doorway.
Here's the idea--
you're playing World
of Warcraft--
sorry, Warcraft 3--
and you see that guy with
the second and a half ping,
and you get really jealous.
Man, I wish my ping
were that high.
So then you start
encouraging your pet
to chew on your ethernet cables,
get those dropped packets.
You really want that
slow, unresponsive feel.
So we take that
desire and mix it
with a platformer to make a
really frustrating game where
as you play it, your
controls become increasingly
unresponsive.
And I think it's
hilarious and fun.
Yeah, it's fun.
Yeah.
Shoutkey.com/doorway.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
Lost Underground.
STUDENT 17: So,
You are a traveler and
you fall down a hole,
and you get lost in
an underground mine.
So the goal of the game is,
equipped with some bombs--
infinite amount of
bombs, because that's
just how games work--
you're supposed
to escape from the underground
by planting bombs and trying
to move through barriers
that you can clear.
The randomness comes in with the
addition of some of ghost bombs
that will be floating around.
And they will not chase you,
but they would go through you
and would explode
at random moments.
So you have to plan around
getting to the end of the level
and also not dying
before you get there,
which is common in a game.
This is a good project
because it's simple
and it's sort of
reminicent of Bomberman,
which is a great game.
So, yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
Dice Traders.
STUDENT 18: Dice Traders
is a multiplayer card
game where you play a card
combo in order to score points.
Importantly, you can trade
your cards with other players
in order to improve your combos.
But if you do that, you might
be giving your opponents
what they need to win.
And so this introduces a lot
of strategic considerations
about things like what
your opponents score is,
how large there hand is,
and so on and so force.
And you have to keep all of that
in mind when you're playing.
And our playtesters really
enjoyed the complex strategy
that arose from these
simple elements.
It would be good for Project
Two because the mechanics
are very simple,
which would make
the game easy to implement.
However, it is designed
as a multiplayer game,
so it would require
some sort of AI.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
And, last but not
least, Gravity Shift.
That is the last one, right?
Nobody else?
All right.
STUDENT 19: So our idea
was for a puzzle platform
with the following
characteristics--
it's a basic platform,
you have a guy
on one side trying
to get to the other
with a bunch of platforms.
Unfortunately for you,
the platforms are all
spaced so that it's completely
impossible to reach them
fortunately for you, you
can place a number of blocks
anywhere you want on the stage.
Unfortunately, again,
they all cost points
and you'll lose points
if you place them.
And every time you land on
a space, it'll disappear.
The twist is, once you
get to the end of a stage,
everything will
rotate 90 degrees.
All your platforms will
become walls and vice versa
and you'll have
to make it again.
If you weren't ahead, then
the second part of the stage
will not possible, which is why
it requires the actual thinking
ahead to solve the challenges.
The reason that this would be
a good idea for Project Two
is because it's a
pretty basic idea,
but it's actually a
deceptively difficult game,
and it's really easy
to make a stage that's
really hard to solve.
PROFESSOR 1: OK,
that was really good,
you all kept to under a minute.
Next up, we're going to
take five minutes, set up
your games, try to
put a lot of space
around where you're set up.
I know it's going to be hard.
But put enough
space around where
you're set up so people can
watch what you're doing.
Take one of these Post-its and--
how the hell do these work?
There we go.
Oh, yeah.
Take one of these
Post-its, put your name
on it wicked big, planted
down on your table
so we know what
we're looking at.
So set up your games, all
the stuff that you might need
is up here in these two boxes.
[INAUDIBLE]
The goal is to make the
[INAUDIBLE] geological center.
So you roll the dice--
PROFESSOR 2: All right.
It's about time,
so thanks everyone.
And first of all, all of you
have playable prototypes.
So for Project One go you.
You were totally there.
A couple of things that I wanted
to say about all the projects--
actually we expected
that a lot more projects
were going to be vastly out
of scope than we actually got.
A lot of stuff that we saw
here could actually just
be fine for Project Three.
A lot of games that we saw here,
once you're a little bit more
comfortable with the technology
and the build process--
and in some cases, it's going
to be just the efficiencies
of knowing the people on your
team a little bit better--
you'll be able to execute any
of these games for something
like Project Three.
But we would like
to actually guide
this next step where we move
from Project One to Project Two
a bit of a better.
So we are going to cut
a couple of projects,
just to make the team building
process go a little bit faster.
Otherwise, having to
select which one of the 15
projects that we're
going to carry on
is just going to
take way too long
than we have class session.
But we didn't do it
completely arbitrarily.
We're going to talk
about our concerns.
If you're one of those games
that we're going to cut,
and you really, really want
to do that for Project Three,
I want you to use the
time over Project Two
to think over your design and
see how you will address all
of these concerns while you're
working on somebody else's
project too, because we
saw a lot of really, really
good stuff here today.
Let's see, so a couple of
games that we're cutting.
Gravity shift we are going to
cut that because the randomness
isn't really integrated into the
design at this point in time.
Again, think about
it, figure out
how you would do that
for Project Three.
I actually had a concern
about the UI of the game,
because a lot of these
games-- sure, some of you
are working in Unity
3D-- that seems
to be a game that UI wise seems
to suggest that it should be
a 3D game, because you need to
know what the sides of the dice
are before you roll things.
But how do you convey
that to a player
in a way that's
not going to have
them to deal with a camera?
And you could also
do it in 2D, but then
how to convey that
information to the player?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 2: Yes.
PROFESSOR 2: Oh, sorry.
That was the feedback
I had for Modgi Dice.
My mistake.
Sorry, I did, in fact,
get that mixed up.
For Gravity Shift,
the UI problem
was how do you
convey to your player
which way things are
going to shift next?
Right?
Is it relative to the player,
or the relative to the level?
When the gravity shifts, are
you rotating the entire level
or are you rotating the players.
Now the player's falling
sideways on the screen.
These are all like
big UI challenges.
Assignments we actually
happens to be about UI,
so that's a good time to
be able to tackle that.
So think about that.
Sorry-- sorry to Modgi Dice.
PROFESSOR 1: For project
three, though, for that one,
still bringing in the
randomness and actually bringing
in the design constraint
for project three
will be important for that one.
PROFESSOR 2: Yep.
OK, then for Final
Flight and Dice Traders,
we have very similar feedback.
Right now, your design
is specifically--
the fun of your games are really
in the multiplayer right now.
That is absolutely fine.
In fact, they are really,
really solid game designs.
The problem is that
project two is really short
and AI is time-consuming.
It's not necessarily hard.
It's just going to take
a lot of time to work on.
So we're going to say let's
not do that on project two.
You might want to save
that for our project three.
Finally, for two more games,
for City Evacuation and Doorway,
actually, technically,
both games are feasible.
I am actually fairly
confident that the games
that you showed today
could be done in the time
span of project two.
However, I feel that a lot
of the fun in those games
comes in multiple
levels-- being able to get
different environments
and different scenarios.
And that's going to be very
time-consuming, which you don't
have time for in project two.
So it's an evaluation.
It's kind of like the
size of your level
and all of your elements
that you've got in it.
It's just going to take
a lot of man hours just
to be able to generate one
map, let alone multiple maps.
Doorway, it seems
to me that playing
through one round of
the game on a computer
can go through pretty quickly.
Actually, where's Doorway?
I like to make eye contact.
Yeah, there.
OK.
It seems to me like
playing through a level,
at least the first
couple of levels,
could go through pretty
quickly, which is fine.
Players like that, especially
when they're wrapping up right
at the beginning of the game.
But that means you have to
generate a lot of levels.
And that's just a lot of
time that you don't have.
So for the rest of
the projects, we're
going to put them up around.
And we are going to ask
you to put your names using
the little Post-its to show
which team you're signing on.
But I still have more feedback,
because the other games
have challenges that you're
going to have to overcome too.
Dragon's Lair, there,
so much information,
so much information for players
to have to understand what's
going on.
How are you going to convey
that over to a player?
The good news,
your information's
relatively static.
It's not like you have numbers
changing in the middle.
[INAUDIBLE], you do
have numbers changing
in the middle of the
game-- so many numbers, so
many little variables
and factors.
So how are you going to
convey all of that information
to a player?
So you have a UI
challenge there.
Beaver Evolution.
There's a-- Beaver Evolution?
You have a range of
possible bad things
that could happen to a player.
How do you explain
that to the player
before it actually
happens to them
so that you can sort of like
anticipate and plan, right?
You could say, oh, well.
They'll play it through
once, and then they'll die,
and then they'll
restart the game.
That's not a great solution.
Think about something
better than that.
Comcastic-- Comcastic,
very specifically
is a UI problem,
because how are you
going to show the
players what they're
about to put down on
the screen, and then
show them the consequences of
what they've just put down?
Because your game is all about
how do I rotate this thing
and then figure
out where it goes
and what's going
to be the outcome,
your problem's
mostly user input--
how to get user input in game.
And Modgi Dice, I
already mentioned it.
How do you do this in 2D?
It's-- yep?
Is that a hand?
Oh, sorry.
I thought you were
putting up a hand.
How do you explain
to the player if you
rotate it, the
dice, this way, this
is a number that's going to
be coming up, versus that way?
If you're going to
do it in 3D, fine.
But 3D's at least twice as long
in terms of development time.
So you have to
keep that in mind.
For Blind Aliens and
Sparkly Redemption,
you're going to
need some art just
to be able to convey to players
what the heck is going on
in your game.
The good news is that as
long as you have some art,
I think you can make it work.
But that's going to
be your bottleneck.
That's going to consume
up all of your time.
Things that we feel
that can probably
work that we're
fairly confident is
within the scope of this project
include Lazy Beaver, Live On.
Lost Underground.
Some of these games resemble
other games that exist,
so you already have kind of
like a template to work on.
For some of the games,
the paper prototype
really kind of already
gives you a pretty good idea
of how the computer
game is going to work.
So I'm not too worried about--
if your game just ran on text,
it could still be
comprehensible.
So I'm not so
worried about that.
But so these are the games
that we have short-listed.
Not all these games necessarily
become project two games,
because we've got-- one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, 10-- 10.
And we're hoping
for teams of six.
PROFESSOR 1: Teams of six.
PROFESSOR 2: We do not have
60 people in a classroom, OK?
So--
PROFESSOR 1: We have about
47 last time I checked.
So about seven teams?
PROFESSOR 2: About
seven teams, so that
means three of these projects
will have to get cut.
And we'll probably
just cut them based
on whether they have enough
people on the team, which
means then the people who
have signed up on those teams
will have to find
some other team.
Now, that's going to
be really obvious.
Once you have your
Post-its up there,
you're going to
see how many people
have signed onto each team.
And we want you to try to get
to a team of at least five.
Six is good, OK?
PROFESSOR 1: So team formation.
Come on down.
Put your name on a Post-it.
You do not need to choose the
game you were on previously.
Once you've put your
Post-it down, sit back down.
Sit down.
Come on back.
We'll read off the names and
we'll see how this is going.
Come on back.
Did you put your name down?
AUDIENCE: What's up?
PROFESSOR 1: Did
put your name down?
AUDIENCE: I did, yeah.
PROFESSOR 1: Then sit back down.
Sit back down.
Sit back down, back down.
AUDIENCE: Can I add my
name if there's already
six on something?
PROFESSOR 1: Yes, you can.
It just means you're
going to get moved
or somebody's
going to get moved.
OK.
If you're not decided, you can
sit down with your name, too.
All right.
Everybody's down?
Lazy Beaver, sorry to say.
Maybe we'll see you
in project three.
We've got three, three,
three-- no, wait.
That's more than three.
Three, three, three and two.
And we've got one, two, three,
four five; one, two, three,
four, five six, seven.
The Future-- maybe
you're moving.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven,
eight, nine-- oh, my god-- ten.
We're cutting that with two.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
You're OK.
One, two, three, four, five.
All right.
So Blind Aliens is set with
Roy, [? Mikael, ?] Miriam,
[? Shalam, ?] [INAUDIBLE],
and [INAUDIBLE].
Apologies if butchered the name.
Blind Aliens, you're done.
Where there any other
sixes that I'm missing?
No.
OK, so the big ones, Comcastic--
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven.
We need at least one to leave.
Is that you, Sam?
Maybe it's Matt.
Julia?
Sabrina?
Anderson, Sean, or [? Tage? ?]
Modgi Dice-- one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine ten.
Devon, Peter, Caleb, Megan,
Jordan, Kevin, Jeremy, Bennett,
Derek, Harry.
Derek, I said big letters.
[LAUGHTER]
You're lucky I'm wearing these.
Anybody I just
named, come on down.
Move.
You have a couple minutes
to discuss down here.
So Modgi Dice, come over here.
OK, great, Comcastic,
taken care of.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] has a
problem that it's just so cool.
PROFESSOR 1: You'll
get to play it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] us.
Look.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
on the ground.
PROFESSOR 1: If anybody on
these other teams are like,
woo, come over to our side.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: Why?
Why do you want people?
AUDIENCE: We're all
very nice people.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR 1: All right.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight--
I need two more people to leave.
Get out.
AUDIENCE: We love you.
PROFESSOR 1: We
need some chants.
Come on.
All right.
Modgi Dice, you are now one,
two, three, four, five, six.
You're golden.
Sparkly Redemption,
you've got five.
We're going to let
you stand for awhile.
Lost Underground,
you've got four.
Beaver Revolution,
you've got one,
two, three, four, five--
ooh, you've got six.
Yay.
Making my life easy.
Plunder Winds, one,
two, three, four, five.
You're cool for now.
Dragon's Lair, you've got three.
[SIGH] Live On,
you've got three.
Lost Underground,
you've got four.
We need one of you
to self-destruct.
Come on down if you
want to self-destruct,
or I'll blow it up for you.
AUDIENCE: Roll a die?
Roll a die?
PROFESSOR 1: You want
me to roll a die?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh my
god, I love this.
This is the best ever.
Ooh.
We've got one, two,
three that we're rolling.
We've got a 6-sided die.
How should I do it?
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
AUDIENCE: But Lost
Underground has four people.
PROFESSOR 1: What's up?
Oh, you're right.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Four.
One, two, three, four,
five, six-- Dragon's Lair.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: It's chill.
PROFESSOR 1: It's cool.
You could do it for project two.
Come on down.
Move yourself.
AUDIENCE: Were you
moving [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR 1: What's up?
Aha.
All right, that's six.
It's done.
Sparkly Redemption,
you've been redeemed.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two, three,
four, five, six.
Plunder Winds, you are all
set to go, to sail away.
How many more of
these do I have in me?
We do have uneven numbers.
Life is unfair.
Randomness, people, randomness.
One, two, three, four, five.
One, two three.
Choose another team,
any team, please.
Live On, choose another
team, any team please.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
That's up to them to decide.
But they can do it if they want.
I don't recommend
it, by the way.
But you can choose any one of
these that's on the board, too.
AUDIENCE: Wait,
anything on the board?
PROFESSOR 1: You can choose
anything on the board.
AUDIENCE: Wait, not [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: One, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven-- you've got
seven choices, so many.
No, too many, too many.
No.
AUDIENCE: I got there first.
PROFESSOR 1: He got there first.
AUDIENCE: I want
to join this one.
PROFESSOR 1: Were you this one?
AUDIENCE: Uh-huh.
PROFESSOR 1: Sorry.
You were second.
You were so close.
So don't choose this one.
And don't choose this one.
One, two three, four,
five, six, seven.
You've got Sparkly Redemption.
You've got Blind Aliens, Beaver
Evolution, Plunder Winds,
or Lost Underground.
All right.
We are done.
[APPLAUSE]
What are we doing
the rest of the day?
AUDIENCE: We're doing--
PROFESSOR 1: You had
two for project one.
You've got five for
project two I think you're
cheating somehow, myself.
Yes?
PROFESSOR 3: I would
encourage, actually,
we ask people to move
around because [INAUDIBLE],
and we just give people spots
to regroup in [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: We meet as teams?
PROFESSOR 3: Meet
at their team tags.
And then find a place
in the room to sit down,
re-discuss vision statements,
and start planning out
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR 1: So no.
Huh, you're right.
I don't have a slide for this.
All right, so we're going
to do exactly as Sara said,
which you did not hear but I
did because I was listening.
Sparkly Redemption,
hang out over here.
Actually, before you move,
what we're going to do,
come down here.
Meet each other.
Shake some hands.
Get to know each other.
Sit back down.
You've got one hour left today.
Talk about your schedule.
Talk about your
vision statement.
Look at your prototype.
Work on your
prototype some more.
Re-write your vision
statement, and talk
about what it
actually means to make
a digital version of this game.
So Sparkly Redemption.
PROFESSOR 3: And
whatever you do,
do not forget to exchange
contact information.
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, my lord.
PROFESSOR 3: Email--
PROFESSOR 1: Were you not going
to give each other your email
addresses?
PROFESSOR 3: Phone
numbers, whatever.
PROFESSOR 1: Modgi Dice.
Blind Aliens.
Beaver Evolution.
Plunder Winds.
And Comcastic.
This is the safe, right?
PROFESSOR 2: That was fast.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
No, it's one of the things
where you might not be happy,
but it gets done.
PROFESSOR 3: Hey, I think
you ran that really well,
by the way.
PROFESSOR 1: Thank you.
PROFESSOR 3: That was a hard
team formation, especially when
people had to jump ship.
PROFESSOR 1: I wanted to just
put one of them on that one,
but I didn't want to be the
one placing people in teams.
PROFESSOR 3: Yeah, and I think
that's the right way to do it.
PROFESSOR 1: Yeah.
What's up?
AUDIENCE: What should
we do with the stuff--?
PROFESSOR 1: Oh yes,
someone just asked.
What do you do with
the old prototype
that didn't get chosen?
Take pictures of it first.
Set it aside.
Maybe put it in an envelope.
And then maybe it
might come back
for project three, so
don't forget about it.